ام
[موسيقى]
تمويل اماراتي لمؤسسات بحثيه وصحفيه في
الولايات المتحده للتحريض على قطر
والسعوديه
دفع اموال من سفير الامارات بواشنطن لمحمد
فهمي وصحفي السابق في شبكه الجزيره لشن
حمله على قطر والمؤسسه التي كان يعمل فيها
تمويل حساب مصرفي يديره الجنرالات في مصر
بدعم حركه تمرد التي حرضت على الاطاحه
باول رئيس منتخب ديمقراطيا في مصر الامر
لم يتوقف هنا فقد كشف كتاب صدر اخيرا في
فرنسا عن تمويل الامارات حمله مارين لوبان
زعيم اليمين المتطرف المتطرف ومرشحه
الرئاسه الخاسره وفقد الصفقه بحصول لوبان
على ال بالمقابل شنها حمله على السعوديه
وقطر المزيد عن ابرز هذه الصفقه في تقرير
نور الدين بوزيان ثم نبدا النقاش
الخزينه احدى المشاكل التي واجهت الجبهه
الوطنيه اليمينيه المتطرفه
لتمويل الحمله الانتخابيه لزعيم ت ها ماري
لوبان وليس سرا انها لجات الى البنوك
الفرنسيه فرفضت تمويلها مشكله الموارد
الماليه جعلت حزب ماري لوبان يبحث عن دعم
بنوك روسيا لكن يبدو ان تلك المؤسسات شحت
فكان على تشكيله ماري لوبان البحث عن بديل
كتاب صدر مؤخرا في فرنسا يكشف فصل كامل
فيه ان الامارات عرضت خدماتها على الحزب
مارين تركي صحفيه في ميديابارت ترصد ناشد
اقصى اليمين منذ العام الفين وثمانيه
اشتركت مع ماستر المتخصص في الصحافه
الاستقصائيه في نشر الكتاب
في يوليو تموز الفين واربعه عشر استقبلت
ماري لوبان مسؤولا في الاستخبارات
الاماراتيه في بيت العائله والموضوع الذي
طرح ومكافحه التطرف الاسلامي وشن حمله على
قطر على السعوديه والاخوان مسلمين ما جرى
يظهر اهتماما وسياسيا للامارات العربيه
وهو لو ان ماري لوبان وصلت للسلطه فانها
ستتحالف مع ابو ظبي لمحاربه الشقيقه العدو
قطر لكن ماذا قال الجانب الاماراتي تحديدا
لزعيمه اقصى اليمين
شخص كان خضر ا في ذلك اللقاء قال نستطيع
مساعدتكم وطبعا نتصور ان الامارات ليس
لديها ما تقدمه سوى المساعده الماليه وفق
ما ورد في الكتاب فان ديوان ماري لوبان
نفى ذلك كما ان مارين لم تعلق على ذلك
ايضا
الكتاب يكشف انه بعد مرور عام على ذلك
اللقاء سافرت ماري لوبان الى القاهره
واجرت لقاءات مع مسؤولين منهم الرئيس
السياسي شخصيا
بعد عام من ذلك اللقاء ذهبت ماري لوبان
الى مصر بمساعدات كثيره من الامارات ونحن
نكشف في الكتاب ان سفرها مولاته وكاله
اماراتيه للاتصال كل لقاءات هاجرت بمساعده
من الامارات بحسب معلوماتنا نحن نعرف ان
القاهره لا تستطيع ان ترفض طلبا للامارات
التي هي حليفتها والمستثمر الاجنبي
الرئيسي ردا على هذه المعلومات خرج الرجل
الثاني في حزب ماري لوبان ل يصرح لقناه
تمويل الامارات العربيه المتحده
ليس مشكله
الكتاب
اصبحت لا تفوت فرصه دون ان تهاجم
والسعوديه
الينا من باريس الدكتور محمد استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
الباحث المتخصص في
اليمين الفرنسي نبدا مع فرنسا والسيد
اه انت شاهدت وربما استمعت لتقرير الى اي
مدى تؤيد ما جاء في هذا التقرير من وقائع
بشان ما قيل عن تمويل الامارات لحمله
لوبين هل لديك معلومات اكثر
قدره الوصول الى المستندات التى تؤكد
هذا الكلام ولكن خلا مرارا
الجبهه الوطنيه اعتبرت ان قطر العدو
الاساسي بالنسبه
الى امنها الداخلي ومن سياستها الخارجيه
ربما قد تلقى دعما من
افرقاء حول هذا الموضوع افرقاء يقفون ضد
قطر وهذا احتمال قد طرح من قبل
اليوم اه تطرح القضيه
نظرا الى المساعدات التي تتلقاها بعد
تتلقى الجبهه الوطنيه من افرقاء روس ولكن
يجب ان تقدم الوثائق والادله الواضحه حول
هذا الموضوع
سيد قام ولكن واضح في تصريحاتها ذكر
السعوديه ايضا هل من دلالات لذلك
الوطنيه يتم التركيز منذ فتره على موضوع
دوله قطر وموضوع تاثير دوله قطر على
السياسه الفرنسيه الداخليه
وتعتبر قطر مؤثره كبيره مؤثره جدا ان بين
ست الى الجبهه الوطنيه وتعتبرها الجبهه
الوطنيه مصر عدد كبير من المشاكل ولاسيما
انتشار ما تعتبره الجبهه الوطنيه تطرفا
دينيا واضح طبعا ان الجبهه الوطنيه لا
انظروا فيما ان كان دول اخرى تعارض دوله
قطر اليوم بالنظر الى الخلاف الاقليمي اذا
كانت هذه الدول الاخرى ايضا عن تطور هذا
النوع من الايديولوجي فهذا امر غريب
بالنسبه الى حزب يعملوا من اجل القوميه
الفرنسيه ومن اجل مصالح فرنسا كما يقول ان
يستهدف دوله مثل دوله قطر
يسعى الى البحث عن ادله حول اداء الموضوع
في دوله غريبه اخرى دوله الشعبيه اخرى هذا
امر غريب بالنسبه الى هذا الحزب القومي
الذي يدعي انه يحمي مصالح فرنسا ومصالح
السعوديه والامارات كثيره عديده في فرنسا
استاذ محمد هنيه انت في باريس وتتابع ما
يدور في الاروقه السياسيه اه هناك ما قاله
الكتاب يمثل فعلا المفاجئه لك ام انها
كانت مجرد مؤشرات او دلائل
اه جمال التقرير كان دقيقا في رصد الظاهره
والجميع يعرف منذ اه مده يعني منذ قبل حتى
قبل الحمله الانتخابيه اه للسيده ماري
لوبان المقالات التي تنشر عنا تورط دوله
الامارات في التمويل المباشر لحمله السيده
ماري لوبان بكل ما تحمله الحمله
اعرب وللمسلمين اساسا فكان الجمع منذ
البدايه بين قطر والسعوديه وهذا هام جدا
في التقرير يعني راينا منذ البدايه اه ان
اه احزاب وممثلين مثلا ليس فقط الجبهه
الوطنيه من اليمين مثلا السيد اه دائما
يصرحون بان العداوه لقطر والسعوديه وقطر
والسعوديه قطر والسعوديه فجاه او في
السعوديه لتبقى فقط دوله قطر وهذا هو
الغريب في المساله اه المساله الثانيه
الهامه استاذ جمال وهذه المزعجه بالنسبه
للجاليه العربيه المسلم فرنسا هو انه من
حق الدول اي دوله ان تستعمل هذه القوه
الناعمه في تحسين صورتها فتكون لديها
مراكز بحوث او الى غير ذلك لكن الكارثه
بالنسبه لدوله الامارات هي انها تمول ان
اه يعني هدفها ليست المائه صوره الامارات
او صوره العرب والمسلمين يعني تحجيم صوره
دوله اخرى التحكيم وتشويه صوره العرب
والمسلمين وهذه هي الكارثه بالنسبه ل
معاداه الحضاره العربيه الاسلاميه نحن
لانه عاده من احزاب او الاطراف فرنسيه لكن
معاده من الدول العربيه
الاموال من اجل تشويه صورتنا وصوره دول
عربيه اخرى ليس المستهدفون دوله قطر فقط
سيدي لكن كل عربي مسلم يجب تشويهه في خطاب
اليمين المتطرف العنصري وفي الخطابات
الاخرى اذن خطوره هذا التمويل ليست في دعم
هذه المؤتمرات وفيات الابحاث والتي
الندوات التي راينا بعضها مؤخرا بحضور
السيد دحلان هدفه هو ربط دوله قطر
بالارهاب يعني انظر سيدي مؤتمر كامل هدفه
كيف استثمارات قطر تدعم الارهاب الجميع
يعرف ان هذا غير صحيح فرنسا لكن هذا
التشويه لا يمكن المتلقي الفرنسي القاعده
ان يبحث وراءه لماذا هو يعتقد ان هذا
الصحيح على العرب والمسلمون الارهابيون
اذن هؤلاء عرب ويقولون ان هناك الاسلاميون
وقطر تمول الارهاب موجود وهذه هي الجريمه
الحقيقيه في حق لا الخليج والسعوديه
والعرب والسنه بل في حق الحضاره العربيه
الاسلاميه ونتحول السيد جانب يعني واضح من
خلال هذا الكتاب وكذلك من مواقف اخرى
لدوله الامارات في عواصم عالميه مثل
واشنطن انها الان تتغلغل في الاروقه
السياسيه هل فعلا تغلغلت في ال الرؤيه
السياسيه الفرنسيه لدرجه انها فعلا قادره
على تحديد بوصله حزب سياسي اه وسياسيه مثل
كانت تقترب كثيرا من قصر الرئاسه الفرنسيه
ولكن هناك امر خطير برايي اه
وهي تحدد للشعب الفرنسي عددا من العداء اه
تلقي باللوم عليهم بالنسبه الى الارهاب
الاخوان المسلمين وقطر بالتحديد وهذه فكره
يروج لها لانه بالرغم من كل شيء مع ان
الجبهه الوطنيه لم يفز بالانتخابات تلقت
ملايين الاصوات
اليوم قار للجبهه ثمانيه وبالتالي صارت
فكره اه يروج لها لدى الفرنسيين ان
الارهاب
موضوع اهم حتى من البطاله
ان عدد من الافكار التي تركز عليها الجفه
الوطنيه
عفوا عفوا عفوا سيد كام ونحن نتحدث هنا عن
تغلغل
الامارات في اروقه السياسه الفرنسيه
بالتحديد
ام
في فرنسا على المستوى الاقتصادي
تاثير موجود ولا يلحظوا الفرنسيين على
صعيد يومي ربما
لان طريقه عمل الاماراتي هذا المجال ليست
نفسها وليست بالوضوح نفسه الذي نرى فيه
قطر حين نساله الفرنسيين حول دوله قطر
يربطون موضوع شانه بين التاثير الاعلامي
لدوله قطر
في اه فريق كره القدم المفرده الذي عدنا
الفرنسيين فريق باريس سان جيرمان
وهذه اشاره واضحه عن وجود دوله قطر او
علاقاتها المقربه مع فرنسا اذا سال
الفرنسيين عما تمثيل هو الامارات العربيه
المتحده اليوم في فرنسا الاغلبيه ستقول لا
نعرف
هذا يسمحوا في
تغلغل هذا الاشهر بطريقه ثلاثه اكثر لانه
غير واضح
سيد كامل ال البعض يقول هناك تناقض
بين وقوع السعوديه ضمن يعني حمله التشويه
هذه اه
التي تمولها الامارات وكما تعرف بان
الامارات والسعوديه حليفه في حصار على قطر
ماذا تقرا في ذلك
الجبهه الوطنيه هذا امر غريب طوال عقود
هذا الحزب شرح لنا ان السعوديه هي مصدر
في فرنسا
لنوع من التطرف الراديكاليه الاسلاميه وهي
المسؤوله عن الارهاب
وفجاه نرى ان التركيز تغير
وبالتالي حزب الجبهه الوطنيه صار يقيم
علاقات مع دول
مقربه من السعوديه وتقف ضد قطر وسائر تلوم
قتل يوم اه على مكانه تلوم السعوديه عليه
وطبعا الجبهه الوطنيه هي حزب سياسي بحاجه
الى تمويل
تجيب عنه المنطقه المتعمق في فتره معينه
وبالتالي يمكن ان يتبع الى اي فريق
عيال لدعم
ولكن منذ فتره عمل على تحديد عدو وهو قطر
والطائره مستعدا لايجاد تحالفت الملائمه
من اجل مكافحه دوله قطر شكرا لك
الباحث المتخصص في اقصى اليمين الفرنسيين
كذلك اه كان معنا الدكتور محمد جميل استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه السوربون